- So my name is Rajit Manohar.
I'm a faculty member
in engineering at Yale,
and we design computer chips.
This is quite a big departure from some
of the topics we've heard from before.
And normally if I gave a talk
that had influence in its title,
people would be wondering what
AI hardware I was designing.
But that's not what I'm
gonna be talking about today.
View me as a consumer of inference,
I have questions about whether
something I'm doing is a good idea or not,
and I want to see if that's true
and how do we go about
evaluating these things
in the design of chips.
So, I'll give you a little
bit of background on the kind
of things that we work on,
just to give you some sense,
because it's quite different.
But it was interesting to
see the talks this morning
because I see many commonalities
and models that are being talked about
in different disciplines.
And you'll probably see
figures that look familiar
to you from the talks we've heard earlier.
So I'm a computer engineer.
What does that mean?
We design and build computers, okay?
So, and this is actually,
most people think of
this as a very, you know,
formulaic process.
But I would argue this
is actually, you know,
I would argue it's more like art
rather than science,
because you are coming up,
it's a creative process.
You're trying to see if
something's a good idea or not.
And this design can happen
at many different levels
of abstraction.
And this is kind of,
you'll see this as a theme
on how we try to understand
if some idea we have
is a good idea or not, right?
And you know, these
abstractions go all the way down
from physics all the
way down to, you know,
the software running on your computer.
And at every level,
there are many sort of
intermediate levels.
This is all subdivided too,
so that we can actually
manage the complexity.
And throughout, even though
most people don't do this,
I have a particular bias
in the way we work on our systems,
and we have mathematical models
that we can use at many different levels
of abstraction, okay?
So, I mean, these are some
examples of things we do.
At the end of the day, we design
something that looks like,
you know, this picture over here,
you can just think of it as geometry.
It's lots of rectangles, different colors,
different colors are different materials.
You're really specifying
exactly what the manufacturer
has to do to manufacture
the electronics, okay?
So, that's the sort of things we do.
And these are engineered systems, right?
So, you think I have full
control at the nanometer scale
of what every little piece is doing.
So, this should be easy.
It should be easy for us to figure out
whether this is good or bad.
It's all, you know, I have full control,
I have software, I can
represent everything,
no problem.
But the problem arises
simply because these systems
are extremely complicated.
So, there are billions of
components interconnected.
It's actually pretty astounding
what we can make today.
Everybody takes this for granted.
We can make systems which
have billions of components
integrated at the nanometer scale,
and they cost $100, right?
Otherwise you wouldn't have a cell phone.
So, that's the kind of thing we look at.
And the question is, you know,
this is the question I'm trying to answer.
I have some idea,
I think this is a good idea,
but is it actually good?
I'm trying to answer this question,
and this idea could be anything.
I have a new way to do, you know,
my latest machine learning hardware.
I have a new way to do my chip.
I have a new way to design my phone.
Is this good or not?
And this is sort of the standard
paper is my card is like,
almost every paper you
read looks like this, okay?
It says we have this great idea,
we implemented the original system
without this idea and with this idea,
and we got these two different numbers.
One is better than the other.
My idea is good, right?
(students laughing softly)
That's all the papers.
But you know,
a lot is left unsaid.
And this is the part where it
starts getting interesting, okay?
By the way, this happens
in many disciplines.
I'm just picking on mine.
So, you know,
a lot of people don't talk
about what didn't work.
And a lot more, as we all know,
doesn't work then does work.
A lot of people don't tell you what's bad
about your great idea.
In fact, if you do that,
you have a very good chance your paper
won't even get published,
because you actually admitted
that this isn't a perfect idea.
And the other,
the thing that is always hidden, I find,
it's very, very rare
to find this is to say,
you know, this idea is only good,
because this critical parameter
has to have this particular value.
And any uncertainty there
is gonna blow it all up.
You know, I had this fun experiment
when I was teaching a class one year
where we were reading papers,
and as homework I made,
I picked a small piece of the paper
and I asked a group of students
to replicate those results.
That's it, nothing else,
and then present the paper.
So, they had to present it first,
and then they had to replicate the results
and then re-present the paper.
And I can tell you that
not a single person
reached the same
conclusions as the authors
of any paper we had read, right?
And these papers are,
you know, famous papers
by famous authors from
famous universities, right?
It was a very interesting,
the students were just shocked, right?
I mean, we all know this is, you know,
I don't think anybody in
this room is surprised,
but anyway,
but I think it was actually very helpful
for the students to
understand the limitations
of what's going on.
So, what are the challenges in the sort
of the world we work
on in computer design?
We have a lot of tools
at our disposal, okay?
So, I should admit that upfront, you know,
this is an, as I said,
it's an engineered system.
Usually we are not trying to do something
that might like, you know,
might create controversy
in sort of the physical
laws or anything like that.
We're very far away from that.
We're typically looking
at classical systems.
Even the ones which have quantum effects.
They have understood models.
We can run simulations at
varying levels of detail, okay?
But I can tell you
that, you know, there's,
depending on what level
of detail you want,
the execution runtime is 8, 9, 10 orders
of magnitude slower, okay?
So, there's just no way you can
do a first principles calculation
to compute what you need to know, okay?
It's just not even possible.
By the way, that eight
orders of magnitude includes,
you know, running this on
the fastest supercomputers
in the world, okay?
So, you know, don't worry,
the computers are faster,
that's not a problem, right?
I always used to joke that we
bootstrap the next generation
of computers by designing faster computers
that we can then use to
design the next computer.
And so that's what keeps things tractable.
Mathematical models,
so there are lots and lots of
different mathematical models
that are used to describe,
and I'm gonna just pick one metric
for this talk, which is performance.
How fast does my computer?
Just one metric.
There are many others,
but let's just pick one.
It's challenging to
capture all the details.
So, the good thing about
a mathematical model
is it allows you to try
to capture the essence
of what you're trying to
model and ignore details.
But the details sometimes do matter.
And then you have to sort of figure out
what's good or what's bad, okay?
So, and I hate to say this,
but this is definitely true.
There are actually
like, you know, sections
of conferences devoted to models
where there's a large community that
writes hundreds of papers a year
and the models are completely wrong.
Well, they're not wrong,
they just don't correspond to reality.
So, and they actually never did, okay?
So, it's very interesting.
But you can prove very nice theorems,
which is a very, you know,
that's why the academic
community sort of works it.
And then the last thing
you can do is you can
actually build the system
and see is this even good?
The problem is, this is
a huge undertaking, okay?
Just to give you some
calibration, you know,
if you can know these numbers
when companies fail, okay?
So, companies like Intel
have announced large projects
that they canceled and, you know,
take a $5 billion hit
on their balance sheet
for one chip, right?
So, these are extremely expensive prop,
it's an extremely expensive proposition.
And the problem is systems are complex.
No one has enough space to
describe all the details
to even do a reproducible
experiment, right?
Even though it's an engineered system,
somebody has a model somewhere,
they don't want to tell you what it is.
So, the other part of this
problem in this particular domain
is companies are making a lot of money,
so they don't actually want
to tell you what they did.
So that's a problem.
So, there's a lot of hidden information,
but the good news is
because there's a lot of money at stake,
when people build these
models and they write papers,
they actually have a very good incentive
to get them right, okay?
Because if they're wrong,
I mean, this has actually happened.
There are major companies
that went out of business,
because the models they
were using were wrong, okay?
It happened, well, 10
years ago, for example.
So, there's good and bad, but I mean,
but if you look at the complexity
of the systems we are trying to model,
I'm now simplifying things a bit.
We've got about 10 billion components at,
you know, individual device level.
By the way, you could go,
you could go to the
materials and the physics,
I'm not even going there, okay?
That's even much more complicated.
And even if you get to like, the scale
of a single chip in the
most simplified model,
you'd have about 1,000
to 10,000 components
all operating concurrently,
all with some complexity in terms
of the internal state, transitions,
and so on and so forth.
So, that's the kind of
systems we're talking about.
So, let me give you a very simple example
of what makes this hard
and show you sort of
an example of what we,
the kind of things we do to
try to model these systems.
So, here is a simple sort of,
there's a standard compute pipeline, okay?
So, what is this picture trying to show?
I have inputs coming in,
and then there are these different steps
for computation.
And the first steps
takes 20 units of time,
and then you hand out,
so it's like an assembly line, right?
You hand over something
to the next step, right?
It's a very simple pipeline,
20 units of time for the first step.
20 to the second,
10 to the third, very straightforward.
And I'm gonna take two
different variants, okay?
One where is 20, 20, 10 and 10, 20, 10.
And my idea is something that
will speed up step two, okay?
I can look at the second system
and say this is a great idea, right?
Things got faster, but if I
apply it to the first one,
nothing improved.
The throughput of the
system has not changed,
because you're still limited
by this first step that
takes 20 time units.
And so you think this is not a great idea.
So, just depending on which
system you're evaluating,
even though sort of locally you are
improving some quantitative
metric, very clearly,
the overall system didn't improve, right?
And this can get,
so this is the simplest
example I could think of
because it's, you know,
easy to understand.
But the networks of these
pipelines that are used
to build these chips have,
as I said, tens of thousands,
if not, you know, hundreds
of thousands of components.
They're not this simple.
Data routing depends on the value.
So, for example, let's
take a very simple example.
Maybe step one takes either
10 or 20 units of time,
depending on what the input data are.
Now, all of a sudden this
becomes a very complicated question.
Depends on the context,
depends on what the actual
inputs might be in real life,
whatever that means, right?
If I run a program where it says,
you running a program, you
might get different results.
So, we actually can have a real difference
in our evaluation of the exact same idea
on the exact same system.
I might think it's good and
you might think it's bad,
and we are both right, okay?
So, this is the kind of
challenge that we have, right?
But you can say, well,
okay, I have this pipeline,
why don't we try to analyze this?
I have some, you know, logical description
of the entire system in
some digital format, okay?
At whatever level of detail, I have very,
I actually have the level,
I have the description
at many, many, many, many
levels of detail, okay?
That's kind of how we can sort of deal
with the complexity.
So, why don't we just analyze it?
Well, it turns out that
if you assume something
as simple as I can represent integers
and simple things like addition,
then everything is
immediately uncommputable.
Like, you know, like because
of Gödel's incompleteness
theorems, literally.
So, you can't compute anything.
So you can say, okay, well,
that assumes infinite
precision arithmetic,
all sorts of things.
So, okay, things are finite state, okay,
well, I only have 2 to the 10
to the 9 states to compute.
So, it's just not tractable, right?
So, these are the kind of
things we grapple with.
And so sort of what we try to work on
is how could we come up with models
that have reasonable approximations
where we can try to do some
of the things we need to do,
try to answer some of
the questions in terms
of evaluating ideas
in a way that's, you
know, reasonable, timely,
something that we can actually use, right?
And I'm gonna show you example,
an example of a very simplified model
that's actually useful even
though it's wrong, okay?
It's an approximation,
but it's still, it's very helpful.
And it was funny,
there's a picture that looks very similar
to this earlier today.
These are models.
The idea here is I've got,
oh, I should just use this.
I've got these little things here.
This is B minus Y OPSI up,
at the lowest level,
well, not even the lowest,
but at a reasonably low
level of abstraction,
I have variables in my system
that can take binary
values, zeros and ones.
This says B went,
B down, so B went from one to zero.
It's with an event, right?
That's very simple.
And these arrows are trying to indicate,
and you know, this is 'cause actually,
we engineered the system.
So, we know that we've
built some physical device
that has B as an input and Y as an output,
and B going down causes Y to go up.
That's because there's
a device that literally
implements this particular thing,
function, feature.
So, you can draw these arrows,
and now these two arrows here
are going to B + that says,
I have to wait for both of these to happen
before B goes up, right?
So, that's the kind of system.
And then this has a cycle.
But that's okay because you
see I've marked the cycle.
The idea here is you unroll this into,
you label all these events,
this is the first appearance
of B down or B up.
So, you tag everyone,
every event with an integer.
So, you can unroll this graph,
but because, remember, I'm
building some physical system
that I'm modeling,
it turns out you can collapse this graph
into a cyclic graph who's unfolding
is actually the computation, right?
That's the idea.
And then, so it turns
out that these structures
have been studied for forever,
including in pure mathematics.
If you're a mathematician,
these are called max plus algebras.
There are lots of theorems
in the field of dynamics
and pure mathematics
that analyze these things
to try to figure out when events occur,
things of that nature.
So, what we can do with
something like this
is we can come up with
some theoretical results.
Now that I have an abstract
model that says, for example,
the model would say that the
time at which Y up occurs
is the time at which B down
occurs plus some delay.
Where did I get this delay from?
That's an abstraction based
on sort of the physics of the electronics.
We know sort of the
time/temporal relationships
between sort of those two events.
And we abstract that as a number, okay?
Again, this is wrong,
but it's quite useful, right?
So, that's kinda what we do.
And then turns out that even though these,
everything is running in
continuous time, right?
You've got millions of these things,
the graph for a normal chip would have,
you know, millions of, you know,
tens of millions of these nodes
for at least to get to the scale
where the analysis is useful.
You'd have tens of millions
of these sort of events
and they all have delay calculations.
This is actually non-trivial
to do all of this stuff.
But you can prove theoretical
results about the model,
which then gives you a very good idea
of how fast your ship is going to run.
So one of the things
you can do, for example,
is if you say, I have
the time for a transition
or an event in this
system, i-th occurrence,
if I denote that by time,
so you can actually prove
that the system eventually
becomes sort of periodic
but not fully periodic,
periodic at an unfolding.
So what this basically says is the time
of the transition at some time
at index iM + J
is some constant
+ M time another constant times i,
so i and J are the two variables here.
So you can see
that all the transitions
eventually become periodic.
So you can actually prove
this mathematically.
It's not fun,
but you can do it.
It's a long proof.
It turns out that there
are simplified versions
of these graphs,
like actually the one here where it's,
I prove this in like
15 minutes in my class
to undergraduates, so I can do that.
But as soon as you start
removing the restrictions
and getting these graphs
to correspond to circuits
that you build,
the proof is a lot more complicated.
But we actually worked
this out not too long ago.
So, that's the sort of thing we do.
And then what we can then do is now
that we have a mathematical formula
for what we know the
system's going to look like
in the steady state,
I can figure out how
fast things are gonna run
when every event happens.
And I can now write software
to take something that only
has a million in, you know,
vertices and edges
and tell me how fast my
chip is gonna run, okay?
And this is actually pretty tractable.
So, you can actually do this.
We have software that does this,
you know, as in the public domain.
That's the kind of thing
we do for, you know,
to try to figure out how
fast the system's gonna run.
But again, you know, this
is an approximation, okay?
A very simple change
you can do to this is,
for example, B going down,
the time at which this occurs is going
to be the max of the two
possible predecessors, right?
Because you have to wait for both of them.
But that doesn't
correspond to most things.
I could just, I could change
when one of my input changes,
then I would get min.
As soon as I add that complexity,
there's an exponential
factor that gets added
to the complexity of the
algorithm that you need, okay?
So it's these,
it's actually very interesting.
So the reason we use this model
is not because it's right,
is because it's actually tractable, right?
So that's the sort of thing we do
to design our systems.
It turns out it's actually
quite useful in spite of that.
There's another set of things
that we do to analyze systems.
And it is funny that
there are the sessions
called causality here.
The technical term that's actually used
in the literature,
in our modeling literature
is actually called
potential causality, okay?
And the reason it's
called potential causality
is because exact causality
can't be computed.
It's too complicated,
so you have an approximation of it
that we call potential causality.
And actually we have the
first results on this
as it applies to circuits.
This idea is actually
very old from the '70s,
which applies to actually
distributed systems
like computer networks.
But we've actually got the equivalent idea
that we use the same words,
because it's basically the same idea
when we are talking about
individual components
of digital electronics
like signals and wires.
And what you can do is very in,
so the way you know if some,
there's causality in our,
in this kind of analysis
is sort of interesting.
What we argue is that if,
so this is a timeline,
by the way, you can never
build this timeline.
It's too complicated.
But you've got a timeline.
I've got all the variables in my system,
everything because I engineered it,
I know every single variable,
not just the inputs and outputs,
but all the internal state possible.
And then I'm gonna put a little dot here
that says the variable changed.
That's all, that's all that means.
And so I can build a timeline,
a logical timeline, okay?
We talk about what everything changed,
and then I can pick a particular variable
at a particular point in time,
and say what caused this variable
to have this value at this time?
And because I have the full topology
of my engineered system,
I can actually say, okay, well,
the first thing I can tell you is the fact
that this variable was
at a particular value
at this time depends on
its own history, right?
So that's what this
horizontal gray bar is,
sorry, the one, this
one right here, right?
The one with X.
And then at this point it changed
and this changed from that
sort of that previous graph
came from these two other
variables having certain values.
So I depend on my neighbors at
that previous point in time.
They depend on their own
history and so on and so forth.
So I can actually build a
cone of dependencies, okay?
That's kind of how we say what what does,
and this is potential
causality because as I
said it's an approximate
approximation, right?
And then the reason we can,
we say that this is potential causality
is because you can now prove
mathematically in the model
that everything outside that cone,
you can reorder in time that
exists an alternate execution
where this node would have this value
at this particular point in time
and everything else can be reordered.
So that in fact it didn't change,
even though it's actually changed.
I could have had an execution,
but it didn't change,
and therefore it's not
causally dependent, right?
So we construct these alternate
executions in the proof
to show that the reason the causality
is limited to this cone
is because everything
else could be postponed,
didn't have to have happened.
Does that make sense?
So that's the kind of sort of theory
that we use to argue
about what's dependent,
and again, this is an engineered system,
so I actually know all the edges, right?
So people are talking about systems
where we don't know
what the variables are.
It is totally different world,
but that's the sort of thing that we do.
Okay, I have a couple of minutes left
and so I thought I would just stop
by just talking about sort of the approach
that the field takes to try
to make sure that, you know,
the results we get with
sort of more abstract models
lines up with when you actually
manufacture the device
and you know, get it.
So by the way, just if,
you may not know these costs,
but to manufacture a chip
costs roughly $5 to 10 million
to get the first part.
And then every additional one costs $50.
That's a very interesting economics, okay?
So imagine if you're writing software,
every time you hit compile you
have to pay $5 million, okay?
So you don't do that too often.
The funny thing is, in spite of that,
sometimes it's cheaper for people
to make the chip and test it
than to run the simulations, okay?
Believe it or not, okay?
I used to always wonder
why companies wasted
so much money fabricating these chips.
And at some point I realized, oh yeah,
it's much cheaper to do
that than to pay the people
to wait for the simulation to be done.
That's why, right?
So it's a very interesting world.
So at the materials level,
I mean, you basically, by the way,
all of these things are all underpinned
by experimental data.
This has been constantly gathered every,
I would say every week, every month
throughout the last 40 years.
Companies are running examples,
universities are doing research.
I mean, there's a huge group
of people working on this
at every different level of abstraction.
They collect experimental
data from materials,
they validate that against
their physics models
or vice rather the
other way around, right?
They validate their models
with the experimental data,
they run numerical simulations
and make sure that they line up.
Once they're happy with that,
those models are then used
to build the next level of abstraction.
So you build models out
of the previous levels
that have been validating
against the lower level
physics of the materials.
And then you build your
device, individual components,
devices, again, these
are fabricated and tested
and you know, all of this happens.
Sometimes the next level,
the whole discipline of
building these models
is sometimes called compact models,
because they're not first
principles physics calculations.
They will be too slow,
they're much more compact.
They're a few parameters,
well, few thousand parameters.
Again, all of the numerical simulations
underpin all of this
at the lowest level of abstraction.
At some point you go to, you
know, ones and zeros, okay?
And at that point, you switch
from pure numerical simulation
to simulations that have
delay values as real numbers.
But then you do this as an
event based model, okay?
So you record what are
the things, you know,
input changes that causes
this output to change,
so many picoseconds later
you record that, right?
And then you scale up by saying, okay,
I now have something
that adds two numbers,
so now I'm gonna say,
and block that adds inputs and outputs.
Again, you are losing fidelity at all
of these levels of abstraction,
but that's essentially how we go about
trying to figure out what's going on.
So I hope I've given you
a flavor for the source
of things we do and you know,
how we try to make sure
that we are not wrong.
And by the way, we are wrong all the time.
I should just just be clear.
(Audience laughing softly)
But,
that's actually partially
why there's very little big change.
If you look at what's in your phone
last year versus this year,
the delta is extremely small,
and the reason is if
you make a big change,
it's like, well, I have no idea
whether it's gonna work at all.
And no one is willing to take the risk
because, you know,
many companies have gone out
of business by doing that.
So it's a very,
it's a sort of an interesting step,
but with that, I'll stop.
(Audience applauding)
- [Priya] We have time for maybe one,
maybe two questions.
Yes?
- [audience member] Yeah, it's a great talk.
So when you prove something
about the higher level model,
there's kind of an additional
proof which is required,
which is about the relationship
between the high level model
and the lower level model.
- Correct.
- [audience member] So it's one
thing to say that, you know,
your high level model, you
know, is periodic or whatever,
but the second connection
is often do you like,
to what extent do you formalize that
or it's just an intuition
as a system designer
that this is more or less correct,
to what extent can that
be made systematic,
this relationship between
the different levels?
- Right, so that's a great question.
So
when you switch from what,
so there are two parts
of the question actually.
I don't know if you intended it that way,
but I think there are two
parts of the question.
So I'll answer that in two parts.
One of the levels is just
going from say materials
to devices to bullion values.
There's that part of the stack.
And at that part,
there's a pretty clear sort
of functional abstraction.
There's basically two
injections essentially
that I use to go from one
information, representation to the other.
And so those are being
crosschecked all the time.
So at that point it's very consistent.
Once you go from the low
level bullions all the way up
to say, you know, a plus to mean addition,
that's no longer the case.
For that, we actually use,
actually, we actually have
the first automated flow
to do this, believe it or not.
We'll see if the paper gets
accepted, most likely not,
where we actually use a
combination of formal,
like formal math, like theory proving,
actually we use a combination
of theorem proving,
model checking, and something
called translation validation.
These are all three ways
to do formal verification.
We need all three, it turns out,
that all of them have
strengths and weaknesses
and we kind of use them
appropriately where we can,
we actually have an
end-to-end mathematical proof
from the highest level of abstraction
at which we simulate all the way down
to the zeros and ones.
But that's actually
like, I mean, as I said,
the paper's submitted,
but you know, it'll get
rejected a few times,
I'm sure, but yeah.
But yeah, that's a great question.
It's a very hard problem actually,
but we, yeah,
because what we found
is the way we can do it
is because the system is engineered,
we track when we are designing the system,
we keep track of side information.
So all of these tools work by searching
in some complex space.
And this search is, you
know, exponentially hard.
But because we know how we designed it,
we can constrain it and
guide it in the right way.
And so we keep the side information along
and then you can do actually
generate a mathematical proof.
Thank you.
-  I suggest
we, thank you very much-
(audience applauding)